[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour cette édition
spéciale ryder cup le magazine sera
entièrement consacrée à cet événement
c'est parti à pour le sommaire l'europe
s'impose pour tous les états unis à 50
ans et bim et récupère le trophée de la
ryder cup
nous étions sur place pour vivre
l'événement sous toutes ses facettes
tous les détails dans un instant
ryder cup 2018 toujours nous évoquerons
la folie tiger woods qui s'est emparée
du public et le tigre n'a pas réussi sa
compétition sur les game reportage à
suivre
enfin nous parlerons de la superstar de
cette semaine de ryder cup le parcours
et les infrastructures qui ont été
construites autour de golf national est
aujourd'hui considéré comme l'un des
parcours les plus beaux du monde coup de
projecteur dans ce a magazine
l'actualité de la ryder cup tva 78
[Musique]
l'équipe européenne est donc ressorti à
victorieuse de cette 42e ryder cup
retour sur les deux derniers jours de
compétition nous étions sur place pour
suivre ce rendez-vous un montage de roma
russe finit des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude 1 au programme
aujourd'hui les deux derniers jours de
compétition vous verrez également les à
côté de cette ryder cup 2018 sont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à peine le golf national ouvert les
supporters un s'empresse d'aller à dans
l'es1 food trucks pour prendre leur
petit déjeuner essentiellement ils
peuvent manger des produits anglais
c'est un très gros événement nous
n'avions jamais fait quelque chose comme
ça avant
je pense que c'est le premier événement
de golf au monde c'est une bonne
expérience nous servons environ entre
3000 et 10000 rothen
[Musique]
une fois restaurée direction les
tribunes les supporters ont mis le feu
comme le vendredi ils sont plus de
soixante mille à encourager les joueurs
sur le trou numéro un
les européens n'ont pas hésité à
déstabiliser les adversaires
[Applaudissements]
les supporters européens brûlant qui ont
permis à leurs protégés de remporter
cette journée de mener 10 à 6 à la fin
de celle ci sa thèse des jours par fait
un bel effort d'équipé très beau jeu de
l'équipe européenne
un bel esprit d équipe de thomasz byrne
et de ses joueurs d'une équipe
nous sommes tous ensemble on s'entraide
c'est qu'avec les plus anciens aux plus
jeunes
nous ne faisons qu'un mais les vingt dix
supporters américains présents golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines ne
désespère pas dimanche sur un grand jour
c'est sûr ce matin ça a été compliqué
mais demain sera une bonne journée et
notre joueur web va nous apporter la
victoire
l'équipe américaine est toujours une
bonne équipe j'ai toujours supporté les
américains évidemment l'équipe
européenne est forte aussi mais en tant
qu'américaine je dois supporter de tiger
et ses coéquipiers comme ça
[Musique]
et
tous
s'il ya bien une équipe qui a
impressionné tout le monde ce samedi à
c'est la paire molinari fleet foot et
ils ont même battu a taillé en mousse
sur deux matches on leur a même trouvé
un solo les mollets woods world signifie
qu'elles veulent faire un fallu et swing
il joue bien avec le mans une source
d'inspiration
sinon y'a pas grand chose qu'on puisse
ajouter à une telle performance il
performance absolument époustouflante
cette baisse résulte de longues
conversations de réflexion avec ces deux
joueurs également de la relation qu'ils
ont ensemble depuis longtemps
il avait envie de jouer ensemble notre
image du jour et les supporters venus du
monde entier emportent avec eux une
histoire ses fans irlandais en voulue
par exemple rendre hommage à leur père
décédé avant la ryder cup un leader et
formique secondes il est mort il ya
quatre semaines sur un parcours de golf
en irlande il était impatient de venir
ici
donc maintenant il est ici et dans nos
coeurs les gens de compétition
aujourd'hui sur cette ryder cup 2018 les
supporters sont en délire on saura
aujourd'hui
qui remportera la coupe entre les
européens et les états unis pour
l'instant option pour les européens
[Musique]
premier match de ce dernier jour de
compétition à le nord irlandais rory
mcilroy affronte justin thomass
l'américain dans une ambiance survoltée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
et c'est finalement l'europe qui
l'emportent c'est tout simplement la
folie sur golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
le dernier point a été emporté par
bolivar et 1 l'italien
ted officiel les européens remporte
cette 42e ryder cup sur le score de 17
points et demi à 10 mois et demi pour
les états unis
l ambiance était évidemment fantastique
[Musique]
et
on a
[Musique]
m
avec
[Musique]
semaine fantastique une grande
expérience pour tous les spectateurs
et puis voilà en fussent à la fin c'est
l'europe qui gagne donc c'est génial je
peux pas refuser
bah oui oui ça c'est c'est c'est la fin
d'une histoire mais messi mairie rendez
vous dans quatre ans en italie pour une
prochaine ryder cup sur le sol européen
à bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
golfique nous sommes de retour en
plateau notre consultant golf pierre
chevallier nous a rejoint pour commenter
à cette compétition
il a pu vivre au plus près cette ryder
cup puisqu'il était volontaire sur
l'épreuve bonsoir pierre bon sens légal
alors comment avez vous vécu cette ryder
cup 2 est vraiment un rêve éveillé c'est
j'en ai encore des frissons et des des
étoiles dans les yeux à découvrir ces
images j'ai vécu ça avec passion avec
intensité
c'est aussi un petit peu
d'investissements perso en tant que
salon de volontaires c'est des horaires
c'est de la présence mais c'est aussi
c'est tellement de bonheur est tellement
de tellement de belles images de sport
là qui vont qui vont rester à vie
l'expérience justement d'une seule vie
et qui valait le coup d'être vécu
jusqu'au bout la victoire de l'europe
est elle logique avec le recul oui oui
oui parce que on l'est on les perdait
déjà même dix jours avant l'événement
dick l'équipe américaine était
monstrueuse et que qui est justement les
exactement ça m'a fait penser par
exemple bruit à la dream team basket qui
s'était présenté à barcelone en 92 on
avait on avait un petit peu enterré trop
vite les européens et avec notamment
avec le tout ce que tout ce qu'avait
préparé thomass viande et ces mecs là le
capitaine européen et ces mecs-là on
montrait une un esprit d'équipé une
force mentale absolument absolument
phénoménale et après un mauvais départ
sur les premiers doubles du vendredi ils
ont su ils ont su remettre les pendules
à l'heure et puis et puis faire une
démonstration que ce soit en foursomes
ou sinon le dernier jour le dimanche en
simple justement les deux premiers jours
de compétition peut-être été déterminant
pour la suite de la compétition
les européens ont mené 10 à 6 à ce
moment là c'était effectivement sûr on
va dire sur les foursomes parce que sur
les quais sur les quatre balles une des
formules du delà de la ryder cup pour le
vendredi matin et le samedi matin les
américains ont presque doublé en 2
contre 2 les américains ont une
ont une capacité justement à jouer à
jouer correctement leur bal jusqu'au
bout ils ont peut-être un petit peu plus
de mal à jouer une balle un coup sur
deux ce qui est le cas de la formule
foursomes et c'est là que les européens
ont planté les premières banderilles un
petit peu déterminante
et je pense aussi après en simple 1 1
2000 points déterminants qui est celui
de polka ici en match 2 en simples qui
est finalement un demi point qui compte
parce que c'était une période où les
américains repasser devant mener un
petit peu de la tête et des épaules les
simples et lahonce nous on se demandait
si justement l'europe allait tenir et
elle a tenu et de quelle manière
alors il ya une terre qui a fait
beaucoup de bruit c'est la paire
fleetwood molinari comment expliquer
cette très bonne entente entre les deux
joueurs quatre matches quatre victoires
donc en double alors qu'il n'avait
jamais joué ensemble
j'avais 10 ans montait à rocard ou qui
sur cette épreuve ils n'avaient jamais
joué en ryder cup
yahia je vois plusieurs je vois
plusieurs points un peu déterminant le
premier c'est le choix de thomas bjorn
le capitaine de les aligner
après avoir discuté longuement avec eux
j'imagine et après avoir étudié toutes
les options pour les faire jouer
ensemble
un deuxième point c'est que c'est que
les deux connaissent etc albatros
connaissent le parcours dont on parlera
tout à l'heure le nouveau logo de france
à deux il ya deux ans donc ça c'est pas
c'est pas notre com
comme comme avantage et puis c'est aussi
le la capacité alors surtout pour fitou
qui est inquiète un joueur un petit peu
plus fantasque il ya un homme un petit
peu plus extraverti de d'haranguer les
foules là on le voit la surveillance sur
ce genre de potes d'aller chercher
l'énergie de la foule
et puis un molinari lui peut-être plus
réservé mais mais mais quelle année pour
molinari le vainqueur de l'open
britannique donc de 2018 golf kempen ça
c'est pas neutre non plus et est un
bonhomme qui arrive à gagner ses cinq
matches sur cinq sur cinq 5 points
possibles 5 trine cinq points pris sur
cinq points de possibles c'est juste
phénoménal et record
c'est un record alors est-ce que vous
pensez que les américains ont pris
peut-être un petit peu de haut les
européens hors jeu sachant qu'il sort
avec la grosse armada avec des joueurs
du top 10 ils sont arrivés confiants
mais je pense qu'ils sont ils sont pas
arrivées préparer c'est à dire que c'est
pour la plupart les on avait on avait
parmi les meilleurs joueurs de la
planète du top 10 top 20 mondial mais
qui ont tous joué pendant jusqu'au bout
quasiment pendant pendant toutes les
phases finales la fedex cup dont ils ont
notamment tiger woods qui gagnait son
dernier tournoi le dimanche qui
précédait son arrivée sur le sol
français
ils sont arrivés non préparés parce que
seulement deux parmi les douze
connaissez correctement l'albatros
justin thomas c'est bubba watson
notamment je sais pas ce qui était sur
le dernier open de france ce dernier
open de force qui est venu repérer en
fait on est venus en repérage sur golf
national et ça et ça dieu sait que sur 1
sur un parcours comme celui là qui est
assez assez compliqué il est important
de connaître un petit peu les les tours
et les détours et puis je pense qu'ils
sont arrivés ils sont arrivés fatigués
ils sont arrivés fatigués parce qu'ils
ont tous joué longtemps les les tournois
mondiaux précédents plus le jet lag et
donc ils sont pas forcément arriver avec
eux a vécu avec trop de confiance mais
ils sont arrivés avec un petit peu de
fatigue dans les bagages alors coup de
projecteur la présence sur l'une des
stars de cette ryder cup
tiger woods l'homme aux 14 grands
chelems était très attendu à 50 ans
melvin après avoir réussi un retour à
triomphant sur le circuit américain
vous l'avez dit justement précédemment
un pierre chevalier mais le golfeur de
la team us n'a pas réussi à remporter un
seul match sur la compétition un montage
de sandrine fonteilles des images de
patrick jacques de dixmude
il est arrivé comme une véritable rock
star sur le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tiger woods le
golfeur américain en 14 grands chelems a
été l'attraction de cette 42e ryder cup
auprès du grand public et pour moi c'est
incroyable de voir e tiger woods donc
oui je suis hyper content c'est un peu
une résurrection
un joueur qui était tombé très très très
très bas et qui a qui est remonté qui a
monté avec beaucoup de volonté
fort de sa victoire le dimanche
précédent sur le circuit américain à
atlanta tiger woods espérait briller
sportivement dans une compétition qui
n'a remporté qu'une seule fois en huit
participations
mais nous avons bien voyagé avec
l'équipe hier soir c'était sympa mais
simplement de passer la soirée avec mes
coéquipiers avec tout le staff
aujourd'hui bon c'était bien de celui
des tendres se dégourdir les jambes golf
tiger woods a finalement été l'ombre de
lui même le tigre est reparti avec trois
défaites en double et une défaite en
simple sur ces quatre matches disputés
sur les greens saint quentinois ryder
cup c'est par son truc au niveau jeu
jusqu'à maintenant alors maintenant il a
encore deux ans pour s'est qualifié pour
la prochain je pense qu'il va repartir
d'ici
avec la cure entre les gens mais
vraiment avec un mal de tête demain
matin après cette ryder cup 2018
tigerwoods affiche désormais un bilan de
13 victoires 21 défaites et trois nuls
en 37 matches sous le maillot américain
l'un des pires bilans de l'histoire dans
cette compétition pierre cheval hier on
pouvait s'attendre à une performance
comme celle-là de la part de tiger woods
cannes défaite
en tout cas c'est une fille aussi
sèchement négative peut-être pas parce
que on savait que que vous qu'il n'était
pas un extraordinaire équipiers la ryder
cup
les stats que vous avez rappelé parle
d'elle même c'est pas forcément le
meilleur joueur en équipe donc notamment
notamment sur les doubles et furie que
la la la ligne et il est trois fois en
double ça c'est quand même c'était un
pari assez risqué bon physiquement on
savait qu'il était un peu juste mais en
pleine résurrection avec son tournoi
gagner donc on ne pouvait pas prédire
qu'il soit aussi
[Musique]
aussi faible en fait sur les résultats
d'un autre côté sa présence sa présence
seresta reste à voir si pour ses
coéquipiers c'était un élément positif
ou un élément négatif
en tout état de cause il ya un grand
vainqueur c'est c'est l'organisation
l'organisation de la ryder cup en france
avec la présence de tiger woods
l'organisation française a gagné à gagné
quasiment dix fois dix fois en termes
d'exposition médiatique les cas voire
non il n'y a qu'à voir le justement les
reprises qu'il ya eu sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur et sur l'ensemble
des médias qui couvrait l'évènement sans
parler évidemment des spectateurs sur le
coach national qui qui ne voulait voir
que tiger
vous pensez qu'il a pris il a pris de
haut cette compétition tiger woods n'ont
certes pas sa priorité finalement son
calendrier il avait quand même
il avait quand même à coeur de remporter
au moins un match au moins un des
matches qu'il a joués
je ne sais pas si furic l'avait déjà
prévenu qu'il voulait le kivu les
lainiers pour trois doubles
si il aurait été salutaire de laisser un
peu au repos notamment sur le deuxième
journée pour justement le bien préparés
sur son simple parce que john ram
c'était quand même un sacré morceau il
ne savait pas au départ mais c'est quand
même un sacré morceau c'est a priori
dans le temps dans ce dans ceux qui
connaissent le golf professionnel
mondial et notamment tiger woods s'est
de toute façon c'est sa marque de
fabrique d'être un petit peu à l'écart
d'être un petit peu d'être un petit peu
sur dans son événement à chaque fois
qu'il s'aligne sur un tournoi et en
ryder cup aussi c'est c'est d'être un
petit peu en retrait de ses partenaires
et c'est là où c'est là où ils vont
éventuellement ça joue notamment sur le
l'alchimie qui peut qui peu ou qui doit
se créer sur des sur des équipes de
double coup de projecteur à présent sur
le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines qui a été l'épicentre du monde
golfique pendant une semaine
le parcours et les infrastructures sur
le site ont été plébiscités par tous les
fans de golf et les joueurs des images
de à patrick jacques de dixmude 1 le
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines est entré dans une nouvelle
dimension et c'est ryder cup 2018 sa
tribune de 6800 places installé au
départ du trou numéro 1 marqué
l'histoire de la compétition en devenant
la plus grande infrastructure jamais
construite pour une ryder cup des
frissons des frissons et des frais sans
un vrai stade de sport un vrai stade de
foot de basket de le stade de france de
golf
c'est vraiment impressionnant c'est
grand déjà et c'est grandiose l'ambiance
est géniale il ya énormément nombre il y
a des yeux rock qui courent d'un côté
des
ils essayent de l'autre et pan oui c'est
grandiose voilà on peut pas dire que ce
soit pas beau c'est un grand succès
français belle tribune enseigner ça veut
tout dire ça fait un peu la france
la zone du roi soleil on n'est pas loin
de versailles
le parcours a également été plébiscité
par les supporters et les joueurs des
deux camps préparé pendant plus de deux
ans avant le début de la compétition
pour un coût de 7 5 millions d'euros
il est aujourd'hui considéré comme l'un
des meilleurs au monde où tant de
travail décent et fait des sacrifices
les voir que voilà tout s'est bien passé
l'image que la france allait amener à
limoux d'un tiers ckx pleine nuit c'est
super sub elle comptait six très piètre
fait d'aimer cqib et voilà comment s'est
passé le golf national va maintenant
retrouver une activité plus
classiquement les prochains mois avant
d'organiser une nouvelle compétition
planétaire dans six ans les jeux
olympiques de 2024
pierre chevalier le golf national
va-t-il marquer l'histoire de cette
ryder cup
je pense défini définitivement parce que
c'est un c'est un parcours qui avaient
été préparés préparer techniquement par
par thomas bjorn
enfin sur les consignes de thomasz byrne
qui avait été préparée techniquement par
les équipes de polars mitage et
d'alejandro reyes
c'était une sorte de piège qui a été
tendu aux américains avec un parcours
extrêmement technique exprès extrêmement
étroits et qui a fracassé les américains
qui sont des gros frappeurs mais qui a
fracassé les américains qui souffrait
d'un manque de précision et et ce
parcours pour la revoir jouer humblement
en tant qu'amateur plusieurs fois c'est
il est redoutable
la préparer pour des pour des projets
pour un événement planétaire comme la
ryder cup il était encore plus
redoutable la différence je souffre par
rapport aux parcours de l'albatros
classique
évidemment ça se joue en termes de
distance parce que les pros par vraiment
des départs les plus éloignés et puis
après c'est surtout sur deux facteurs le
premier c'est la largeur des fermes et
donc la largeur de la piste en herbe qui
va du départ jusqu'au green ou là là là
c'était assez étroit et puis il y avait
des ruff l'erreur c'est l'herbe un peu
plus haute qui est sûre les qui borde le
keyboard le fer bois qui borde le
parcours à partir du moment où une balle
tombe là dedans c'est on perd
automatiquement un coup à se recentrer
sur le fairway parce que justement le
rough mange la balle et là les
américains ont payé pour le voir c'est
il y en a plusieurs qui se sont cassé
les dents et casser les poignées de
dents et la deuxième facteur c'est la
rapidité des green a priori bjorn avait
demandé à ce que est ce que les greens
soit soit travailler de manière de
manière évidemment extrêmement
professionnelle mais de laisser un petit
peu poussée de ne pas trop de ne pas
trop ton droit de ne pas trop stresser
le gazon de manière à ce que les la
balle n'aille pas trop vite vers le trou
est en fait on a vu la différence est
que les américains sont très habitués à
jouer sur des greens très rapide donc ça
ils sont plutôt bons là dessus et quand
quand la balle ne va pas suffisamment
vite pour eux ça se ressent sur leur
petit mieux très rapidement cette super
tribune à vous a impressionné 6800
placement et comment j'ai eu la chance
d'être donc au trou numéro 2 pendant
tout l'événement et on avait vraiment
une un stadium 2 comme disait paul
hermitage un stadium de golf
c'était une arène entière qui
vibrer à chaque clapping à chaque à
chaque départ de joueurs avec les olé
olé
les chansons pour l'europe les les
chambres pour les pour les américains
c'est assez unique de voir ça sur un
parcours de golf et avec un public six
disciplines essifer plessis sportif
c'était juste géant quelle sera la suite
justement pour ce golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et pour le
golf en france les réponses dans le
reportage qui va suivre dépassé le
chiffre des 410 mille golfeurs licenciés
c'est l'objectif clairement affiché par
la fédération française avec
l'organisation de la première ryder cup
sur le territoire français la structure
espère bénéficier de ce coup de
projecteur planétaire pour attirer de
nouveaux adeptes
on pense qu'après cette ryder cup
évidemment un plus grand nombre de
personnes auront eu un premier contact
avec le golf et on espère que bien sûr
ils vont se mettre à jouer au golf pour
créer une nouvelle génération de
passionnés la fédération française à
parier sur la jeunesse en lançant dès
2015 à saint-quentin-en-yvelines mon
carnet de golf sur la ryder cup
un programme éducatif ludique pour les
cm1 et cm2
le succès qu'a remporté 7 cette
opération a poussé l'éducation nationale
à étendre l'opération sur tout le
territoire
donc oui ça a marché ça continue à
marcher et ça va encore marcher la ryder
cup 2018 va également permettre au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
se faire un nom avec sa rénovation à 7,5
millions d'euros l'albatros est
considéré comme l'un des meilleurs
parcours au monde un standing qui lui
permettra d'organiser de nouvelles
compétitions internationales dans le
futur nous voulons poursuivre cette
politique d'accueil de grands événements
pour montrer les concrétiser toujours ce
savoir faire français et que la ryder
cup nous a offert et pourquoi pas je dis
pas que nous ferons mais on pourra y
réfléchir après la ryder cup
accueillir la salle polyvalent féminin
en attendant la solheim cup le golf
national accueillera en 2022 les
championnats du monde et en 2024 les
jeux olympiques
le golf à saint quentin en yvelines une
histoire d'amour qu'il devrait durer
pierre chevalier vous êtes aussi
confiant que jean louis charon sur
l'avenir du golf national sur l'avenir
du golf national oui et du golfe au
niveau national j'ai plus d'attentes
mais mr peut-être un petit peu plus
d'inquiétudes sur golf national oui on a
placé le golf français sur la carte
mondiale du tourisme golfique la france
était connu pour ses innombrables
richesses touristiques
maintenant avec un événement avec cette
ampleur médiatique là on a placé on a
placé le curseur sur sur la france comme
destination golfique plus pour les
étrangers du coup oui pour les we pour
les étrangers mais aussi pour les pour
les français qu'ils les qu'il le
connaissait et qui et qui maintenant
vont vouloir les jouer ou rejouer une
ride devenu où c'est à dire un parcours
qui a qui a accueilli 7 cette ryder cup
il ya peut-être eu un seul regret là
dessus c'est que c'est qu'on n'ait pas
eu un joueur français dans le dans
l'équipe c'est léo leur gré principal
qui aurait fait que la fête aurait été
vraiment belle à 100%
vous pensez qu'il pourrait y avoir une
nouvelle ryder cup en france au golf
national dans les prochaines années
c'est assez peu probable parce que le
dans l'histoire depuis 1927 il ya assez
peu de parcours qui ont accueilli la
rider 2 fois il ya éventuellement un
parcours américain qui aura été classé
comme ça mais en europe veulent des
rahman l'avait accueilli qu'une fois en
97 il y aura rome en 2020 maintenant ça
sera donc ça sera dans un certain
certain nombre d'années si jamais ça se
représentent les médias ont-ils assez
parlé selon vous pour permettre
justement golf de se démocratiser sur la
sur la semaine louis c'est je pense je
pense des médias des médias presse
presse écrite notamment votre chaîne
des chaînes les chaînes de canal+ bien
évidemment qu'elle achève la chaîne du
golf
pour les autres c'est quand même très
dommage qu'on n'ait pas pu voir sur des
chaînes publiques et sur des chaînes de
grande écoute
au moins des reportages et une
couverture de l'événement autre que sur
l'annoncé du résultat
vous pensez que les images diffusées
peuvent bousculer les préjugés qu'on a
souvent sur le sur le golf golf soins
associés à sport de vieux sport de riche
est-ce que ça ça peut bouger avec ses
images de ferveur populaire qu'on a pu
voir je l'espère s'en sert de même pas
ce que c'était vrai mais c'était c'était
un des paris un des paris de
l'organisation de cet événement là
c'était justement de changer l'image que
le grand public et du golfe
la présence de tiger woods a donné
l'assurance justement d'avoir une
d'avoir une couverture médiatique la
plus large possible ça c'était sûr parce
que tiger hill et et le golfeur le plus
connu au monde même des non golfeurs
donc sa présence déjà assurée à assurer
une bonne réussite à l'événement est ce
qu'on a vu là est ce qu'on revoilà à
l'image c'est c'est un sport qui est
spectaculaire qui est populaire qui est
facile et facile à suivre tout le monde
voyait bien là du coach national
c'est là aussi où il s'est fait vraiment
une une image tout mon voyez bien des
buts du national et de cette tribu de
6800 place il y avait une ambiance de
folie une ambiance bonne enfant sportive
avec des jeunes des moins jeunes et très
vieux donc là pour le coup oui le golf
changera son image comme ça merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau pierre
chevallier et de nous avoir éclairé sur
cette ryder cup pour vous retrouvera sur
cette chaîne dans l'émission assez on
parler sport c'est la fin de cette
émission spéciale à ryder cup merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]